i think there's absolutely one universal
characteristic of getting older
is you don't think things are quite as
bad as
younger people think they are
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kissen
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our brilliant guest today is an
author and guardian journalist simon
jenkins welcome to trigonometry it's
great to have you on the show uh before
we get into the conversation self tell
everybody a little bit about who you are
how are you
where you are what has been your journey
through life
how long have you got a lot we've got an
hour so far away
no i left university i think i wanted to
be an academic and i wanted to use
academia as a way into politics i was
interested in politics
sort of mildly left to center then
uh i didn't like academia i disliked
universities very much i spent a year
and a half in one after graduating and
chucked that in
um i became very interested in politics
because it's
to me it's the sign of a living person
they're interested in politics
but
but i was a journalist from student days
and i always loved journalism and i
still do and i've done it ever since
in that time i've done other jobs i've
done other sorts of i've been editing as
well as writing and journalism um i i
believe journalists should do other jobs
as well because it gives them a taste of
what the rest of
life is like
um and uh written books on architecture
history and so on but um journalism's
right i i can't stop having an opinion
great and look you've had a
distinguished career of course
one of the things we were talking about
before we started is francis you know
the depressive character that he is was
giving you all doom and gloom about
where we are and talking about how we're
in a political crisis and you were sort
of going well yes but so give us the bug
give us a historical but to that to that
perspective i think there's absolutely
one universal characteristic of getting
older
is you don't think things are quite as
bad as as younger people think they are
i mean you think everything's bad
because that's that's what old people do
but um there is a sense in which you've
seen it before
and i always remember my parents saying
to me no one could understand the
interwar years in britain who knew about
the second world ball
you just you you had to know
or experience the pattern of events
to judge the past and this business at
the moment of endlessly judging the past
or rejudging the past i just find very
offensive
because you know we aren't there we're
here um we're not in a position to judge
we're in a position to record and see
what's happening but it's easy to say
every i mean when i was a student we
thought our politicians were rubbish
absolutely rubbish
and looking back at them we think they
were titans you know these are great men
um and i'm sure it's the same today
i i i genuinely think that the present
generation of politicians in britain are
the worst ever
couldn't disagree certainly the worst in
the 20th century but i then stopped and
think to myself you know i was a student
in the heath government we thought they
were useless uh the labour government
the country was a terrible mess in in in
in the mid to late 70s a real mess
thatcher was hated
um
i think she was actually a very
interesting prime minister but she was
hated um
it's a part of the duty of democrats to
hate their government
the sign of a good democrat democracy is
it votes its government out of office
regularly
so i'm i'm fairly sanguine about the
state of the world and i do think that
that i've always thought democracy was
never necessarily good to triumph um i
mean dictatorship is a much more popular
form of government really
but at the same time um things do get
better i i'm with stephen pinker fewer
people get killed every year uh more
people
survive and don't die of starvation
there's a genuine sense that mankind
progresses i don't get hysterical about
global warming i'm i think it exists i'm
not a denier
but i suppose i'm i'm a mild optimist in
my general outlook on the world
that's very interesting we it's very
rare to have a mild optimist in in the
chair simon and
why are you a mild optimist what is
there to be optimistic about at the
moment do you think
well it does you go to you read about
the 14th century occasionally
you know i i it's often people say what
what year would you most like to lived
in i mean i i can choose a few and i'm
certainly 1492 i'd love to have been
around then discovering america and
christianity was triumphing in a brutal
way and everything was going on in 1492
and then like 1868 when they're building
railways are a very exciting time
they're periods like that
but i just do think
statistically
i believe in facts things do get better
each year i mean not everything gets
better for god's sake but things do get
better each year and when something
happens like afghanistan you think hold
on a minute you know afghanistan's had
20 years of of sort of joy
and now
it's gone wrong
which is the normal
i just don't know which is the normal i
mean
much of the muslim world is in a
terrible state now well that's their
business not mine
and
at least i'm not
bombing everyone still as i were as i
was 10 years ago
it's an interesting point i think i
would disagree with you that things get
better every year i mean they get better
every century uh but within that century
there's a lot of fluctuations and i
would argue we're living through one but
let's come back to your point about
politicians because
i take your point and i'm sure as i get
older i will be the same but the the bbc
recently put out this drama uh
documentary not drama with tony blair
and gordon brown i don't know if you saw
that
i thought it was very good and actually
what the bbc should be doing
and
i couldn't help watching that
and think look i i disagree with a lot
of what tony blair did iraq and you know
mass immigration policy etc but
the caliber of people that were in that
documentary
seems to me to be completely off the
charts compared to the people that we
have now who've been media trained out
of their brains who will never say
anything that you can actually convert
into actual coherent thought
who who are not people of
you know significance or talent in my
opinion i i don't know most of them and
i'm interested in politics very
interested so wouldn't is it not fair to
say that the sort of caliber of
politicians has declined i don't think
so you don't think i don't i don't i
mean it is it is you don't think it is
tony blair is there's a big difference
there it's a genuine generational
fallacy that you've adapted i think um i
mean the famous parliament of of 1918 um
when someone looked across the house of
commons all they could see were fat cats
who'd done well out of the war it was
the famous phrase they produced you know
everybody was corrupt everybody was was
second rate um uh and yeah they got us
through the mid-war period that goes
into the second world war i suppose but
it was you know it
you've just got to try and put your
perception of the present
in terms of the past if you're if that's
the judgment you're making you can say
look this sort of useless and we've got
the hell ahead of us and they're not up
to it that's a different judgment but
looking to the past and saying they're
worse than the past
um i'm just i'm just reluctant to form
those judgments but simon come on you've
got a leader of the labour party and by
the way boris johnson's know better who
they don't know what a woman is anymore
right i mean we didn't have those sort
of people 20 years ago we just didn't
you didn't know who what a woman was
yeah kiestarma was asked do women have
cervixes anyway
that was his name well he he he was
trapped by the present distillery you're
quite right yeah
with you there yeah um but no i think
kiersten is perfectly adequate in
comparison with most other politicians
since the war i really do um boris
johnson's an eccentric he's a real
oddball let's put it that way um rishi
shin like he's not michael gove is not
these are people who could have served
in in thatcher government or macmillan
government or where it was um
i i just don't leap to conclusions about
people's character and personality until
they're put to the real test and let's
face it the last 18 months has been a
real test i mean i don't know where
blair would have been in that and blair
was a remarkable politician let me say
so in a sense comparing him to
stalin he had charm
politicians who have charm have it all
made for them as boris johnson has been
showing in the past um so uh i mean the
qualities that make a great leader
very difficult to pin down i mean
someone alec douglas hume he was a
fantastically popular man he's a useless
prime minister he was popular and he
almost won an election i mean he was it
was extraordinary so i'm just reluctant
to rush to these sorts of conclusions i
want to judge them by their outcome by
what happens we do tend to have a very
weird relationship with the past don't
we where we either romanticize it or
want to tear down figures from it it
seems to be a very binary approach to
the past
i think i think it's a it's a fault of
political conversation generally the the
binary approach
i don't know i mean i was kind of
brought up school studying classics and
my teachers want obsession with socrates
and we spent a whole time studying
bloody socrates
but the thing i learned from it was the
dialectic method the concept of
polarization um what are you saying what
are you saying can we have an argument
don't pretend you agree let's see if you
disagree let's fight it out and i
passionately believe in debate that's
why i believe that the media must be
polarized in some sense um
with all the reservations you might have
about that
um but i mean i just i i i do think that
that the um the concept of there being
differences the concept of being
different points of view is embedded in
political conversation and if you
smother it
uh even if you say well can't we find a
compromise
you you you you're running a risk
you're running a risk you come to the
wrong conclusion in something but we
don't seem to have debate as much
anymore do we where people and again
push back on this uh it seems that we're
more polarized than ever we're in our
little silos and society seems to be
that we we we don't want to talk to
somebody who disagrees with us
is that is that me looking at society
now and
and romanticizing the past again or is
there is there a truth behind what i'm
saying no you're romanticizing the past
okay great thanks i mean i mean i i i go
back to all right
hopeless my generation we always i go
back to the center i go back to the 60s
that's when i sort of had my political
education
and um and i go back to a time when when
every play in london was censored
gays were sent to prison
uh divorce was exceptionally difficult
um abortion was banned
uh and i can't think of the the list
of of of activities that were in the
church was immensely powerful um
and no one challenged it
oh you you make the point i mean no one
challenged it somehow that was
acceptable let's not push let's mess
around the boat i mean
immigrants are all
you know i mean
it was it was looking back we said well
that's how we live and it's how people
in muslim countries now live so i'm
familiar with that syndrome but it
existed in britain
um i mean the taboos that that exist now
have mostly gone
but they've mostly gone to booze we have
new ones now we we we we've got you
you've got new ones
there to do with personal identity they
have to do with race that you do for
some reason drugs which fascinate me um
but i mean that there are taboos so
you're absolutely right um
paying for health is still it's a little
bit taboo
in every other country you pay and you
get paid back if you do but you you pay
um so i just don't think is that
different i really don't
and as you said they're new to boost
well that's that's what i mean i think
what what people like me feel is i
admired people and
watched comedians for example who pushed
back against that religious dogma
and i thought that was important in
order to liberate individuals from the
oppressive ideology of state-sanctioned
religiosity or whatever that might be
and having gone through that i sort of
thought well we've got somewhere we've
made progress here but
what i feel like has happened more
recently is instead of stopping there
we've we've gone to a new form of
progress which has now become a new
religion that is imposing its own taboos
on society
i think i mean
i agree i mean i found the whole concept
of cultural wars uh odious and um
you know
up to a point worrying if i thought that
more than 17 percent of people agreed
with them i'd be more worried the
question is what's gone wrong with the
other 87
um
and uh and that's that's a different
conversation but um but no i mean i i i
what i'm saying is i think we've pushed
so many boundaries um
back to to what might be the liberal
extreme it's almost inevitable there's a
there's a push back on that well
obviously yeah um and and it's it's to
be expected i mean you know in america
now where
the education system appears to be
trapped
by a sort of um ethos dogmatism
you know
they lose the election
people put up with it no and i i i
because i just believe that most western
societies
lucky enough to be blessed with the
european liberal ethic
do have within them pushbacks
um
uh
there's a the american i used to see
whenever i went over there um to to
report whatever i was doing it was an
elderly philosopher i can't remember his
name um and he always said to me
whenever i was saying how can you put up
with this man nixon how can you how can
you tolerate reagan i mean what's going
on he always said
the american constitution is not built
the way yours is
with an ongoing conversation within a
civilized parliament we go right to the
boundary we go to the edge of the cliff
we're about to fall over the cliff
and
and the elastic in the constitution
pulls us back at the last minute
and interestingly i wish he'd been alive
when trump was around because
you almost went over the cliff but he
would have said that we pulled back
now
you know you pull back to joe biden
that's quite some point
not just that but i mean if trump comes
back right it's a very interesting
article in the statesman saying i mean
what literally happens if trump comes
back what literally happens if he wins
i mean um this is going to be the
ultimate test for the american
constitution and i do believe that i can
see that as a plausible scenario i can't
quite believe it's going to happen but
there we are um
is johnson going to stay there 10 years
then what dear god
but
hey constantine do you love trigonometry
of course incredible interviews
hilarious live streams hard hitting
satire plus my handsome jawline whatever
takes away from your hairline but if you
do love trigonometry and you want to
support us there's only one place to do
that and that's on locals yes locals is
a brilliant platform that has been
incredibly supportive to our show and
other problematic creators the great
thing about locals is that it's a
community for people who love
trigonometry that's right it's a place
for you to hang out with like-minded
people share thoughts memes and discuss
the show you can enjoy it for free but
it also gives you the option of
supporting us for as little as seven
dollars a month and if you want to give
more you can we have incredible rewards
for our higher tier supporters as well
we've got everything from mugs monthly
group calls and one on two chats with me
and kcat get in join our community by
hitting the link in the description and
the pin comment below see you there guys
looking at trump and looking at
johnson
absolutely decimating the opposition
and being a person of the left as i am
do you not think simon that the left
needs to take responsibility for these
victories and actually
say that they're not appealing to the
ordinary working person they're not
making that connection well hold hold on
i mean the the the the left
or chunk of the left is critical from
there deserted labor voted for johnson
now those same people appear from the
polls to be revolting against him
because they didn't like much in his
form of government
that's the system
hitting back um i i i do think the
british constitution has his ability to
to you know bite back and i like it
that sort of works um
uh
by the same token i was
desperately disappointed during the
brexit argument without getting involved
in the actual argument itself but it was
clear that parliament was very upset by
not just brexit but hard brexit by the
approach the government was taking
intransigent hostility all these things
were bred into it and parliament had an
opportunity
um
when may was in real trouble to seize
control of the executive from
the government
and say we want these following things
to be done and the labour party then and
the liberal democrats and the scott nats
the various opposition parties in
parliament um could have got together
and never did
and i remember thinking that i thought
that was the death of parliament the
parliament is none just an electoral
college and nothing else
when offered the chance to take a lead
he couldn't do it
uh and
i mean quite a few quite senior labour
figures i know thought do we do he
seized control in some sense
and and just
couldn't find it in them to do so
party discipline being what it was
um
so
you know we do we do go near the edge
occasionally and we sometimes
fail and i think in that case it failed
i don't think johnson's victory was all
that surprising um i don't think it's a
catastrophe i think he's
he's a very old man and i know a bit
he's a very old man
my wife was at university with him and
knew much better
but uh but no i mean the the politics is
fascinating it's always changing it's
always different and i'm just not a
catastrophist
and and do you do you think the left is
going to actually capitalize now on
johnson's fall abilities the the the
sleaze scandals are hitting the
conservative party do you think they're
actually going to be able to make
in-rows into that
into the red wall as it were and reclaim
those heartlands i haven't the fog is an
ocean okay i think i think i think
i think the answer is probably yes
um really i don't think star wars
finished i think he's he's i think he'd
be regarded as a decent man an honest
man um
he's got a long lot to learn i mean
don't try and play johnson's game i
would have just stood aloof from johnson
and just
appeared to be a respectable potential
leader he's got a big problem with
talent um in the labor party he's not
getting good people into parliament um
it's cr the liberal the liberal
democrats to me are the the the tory
buddy in disguise i mean they're the
tory parties useless useful idiots
they're always sitting there taking
votes away from labour just at the
crucial moment when labour most needs
leftist central support
um and the the liberal party are tories
in the sense that they do not want
labour to win
because if they wound up or did deals on
seats with labour never to contest a
potential labor victory uh labour party
would win
as with as with scotland
scotland
i'm doing a book about
the celts at the moment i mean it's just
phenomenal to me that the scots haven't
gotten to play with labor
or labor with the scots
because that's you know that's 50 seats
it's completely crazy
you you genuinely think the labour party
as it is now obsessed with identity
politics unable to speak to ordinary
people about the things that actually
matter to them economic inequality
housing all this they don't talk about
it they talk about all this other sort
of metropolitan liberal stuff that we
love to talk about here in london you
think they're going to make a comeback i
i well
yes i do because they always have
i mean ev i mean
in the early 1980s in this country
everybody was completely finished yes
i mean in in in in in the late 50s it
was finished mark abrams wrote a book so
why must labor always lose i mean these
books have been written for 50 years
right um
everybody starts new parties on the
right and on the left and nigel pharaoh
is still mucking around with some party
called ukip or whatever
the sdp is trying to re-found itself
liberal democrats refuse to
shut up
and yet labour part of the labour party
does come back now
it does need a blair
well that's my point it needs someone
who needs someone who can talk the
language of of of of not the extremes be
those extremes those of uh
industrialized labor or of um identity
politics um uh i'm assuming that the
kirsten at some stage or in some sense
can can capture that particular
initiative you don't do it with an hour
and a half speech at your party
conference which that's for sure but um
but um
the the system has built into it the the
the reaction the
the reaction to superiority
so i'm just assuming that will happen i
may be completely wrong but i'm it's
always happened before so your argument
is not so much that you see in the
current labor party the seeds of
recovery but rather that
historically this is what always happens
parties go through downfalls they they
lose a lot and people get fed up of
losing and then blair comes along this
is francis and i had an argument about
this the other day on camera and it's
very much what i was saying actually um
so i'm challenging you from a devil's
advocate point of view more or less but
um it strikes me that i mean i i i'm not
saying this to flatter you but you do
seem to have very sensible views about a
lot of these issues
the culture war issues particularly i
was told i'd never be on television well
that's that's a guy because because they
can't you can see we don't know where
you're coming from yeah
coming from here you know well quite i'm
sorry about being sensible
and that's what we tried to do on the
show much much the same as you so
forgive me for this question but i have
to ask you you work at the guardian
how do you manage to do that
well the guardian publishes what i write
they pay me to write it and they publish
it i got no problem yeah um but next to
that is an article about how skyscrapers
are signs of toxic masculinity spewing
male 1 actually whatever into the
atmosphere actually i rather agree with
that point
along with that one for sure i hate
skyscrapers
little georgian houses yeah that's fine
but i'm not sure there's signs of toxic
masculinity spewing
male 1 whatever into the atmosphere i i
did want to write an article it said
exactly that it was all there
probably epic politicians with the um
erectile dysfunction
[Music]
i mean they are a feature of of of male
planning in some cure architecture not
playing architecture plan is a different
matter no i mean be that is it made no i
mean the dear old guardian is fine i
mean the guardian needs to be there i
i'm i'm proud of a country that
publishes the guardian and that paper is
now second or third most widely read
quality paper on earth um and that's
thanks to online um uh i i got no
problem with it at all it's it's it's
not
monotheistic or monolingual
um it it has many points of view
reflected in its pages he's broadly
speaking left to center that's true um i
wouldn't say i'm broadly speaking left
to centre because i cannot place myself
anywhere on the spectrum almost every
issue i find i'm
on the opposite position which someone
else i thought i agreed with is on
but uh uh no i mean i i i
there was a time i remember it well i
read a book about the press ownership
back in the
1970s i think
in which the of the seven british
newspapers first thing about newspapers
i may say is when i entered newspapers
everyone thought you're mad
the future is broadcasting
as they now say the future is podcasting
and so um newspapers are dead they're
made of made of dead trees with dead ink
the dying people they're finished
there were seven newspapers daily
newspapers in britain then there was
room for two or three we were told by
pundits in the industry
they're eight today
um
they have a longevity that defies
everything but there was a time then
when the only papers of the left
were the daily herald the
uh the guardian and the um and the daily
mirror
daily mirror was up for sale daily
herald gone bankrupt and bought by
murdoch or became the son
and the guardian was stuck in manchester
uh if the daily mirror had gone to a
right-wing owner they would not have
been
a a liberal voice or left-wing voice in
british press i really thought at that
point the government had to act
now the system
for no reason to do with public policy
at all the system has nonetheless
delivered a diversity of opinion
throughout my life but my whole life is
extraordinary
and the daryl bbc keeps it going against
all you know knocks to its um
pride and so on and it behaves
idiotically and yet it's still there yet
it's still diverse and we're terribly
lucky in this country but my my son is
in california
he just i i can hardly bear you know
not like he gets the bbc online all
sorts of ways but american press and
when i go to america i feel quite
frightened
um
but i guess the reason i was asking
about how you feel at the guardian is i
think i i look i don't want you to you
know be throwing your colleagues under
the bus at all it's not what i'm trying
to do but it has changed they threw me
quicker than that
it has changed
hasn't it oh i think oh yes it has i
mean all papers do change no it has
changed i mean okay let me rephrase it
change in the direction that i
personally think is wrong well
you disagree with it
no no no no no no i like you think it's
very important that the guardian exists
i just think
uh it ought to do sensible articles of
the center left which i happily read and
enjoy and sometimes agree with
all of this
moronic cultural stuff i think is very
off-putting and it undermines
the reputation of the paper as a whole
for me
well i'm i'm i'm i'm i'm sorry you feel
that
there we are i mean
wha what what i i just do think it's
very important for there to be a public
voice for all points of view even
even in a polarized political
environment i really think that um i
mean the guardian the garden used to be
the manchester guardian it was a liberal
paper it was not a labor paper um and i
remember it as being almost intolerably
compromising on every issue um it's not
that anymore you're quite right it's
it's it's it's it's a champion as a
banner waiver for the left of the
political spectrum it is not of one
voice any more than the left of the
spectrums of one void to put it mildly
and i think the guardian does struggle
to
represent all points of view
within what might be called the broad
left of the spectrum um and a number of
articles that
drive me up the wall as they drive lots
of people at the wall and not surprised
they probably drive you up the wall but
i'm glad they're there and i do think
that the most important thing is the
guardianship
of diversity in the press and in the
media if the guardian wasn't there there
would be a very severe lack of diversity
and i feel that quite strongly you mean
diversity of thought yes yeah
we often use
the terms diversity but they tend to
mean different things now don't they we
don't tend to talk as much about
diversity of thought and i'm really glad
you brought that up why do you think
that is simon
well diverse the word diversity has been
hijacked by identity politics um and
that's you know
says so much at the moment um you could
discuss whether i'm a as a
economist about that as i am about other
things because i think there are dangers
in that um but but i mean i've always
used the word diversity of the press as
representing diversity across the left
right spectrum that spectrum is now is
now
corrupted to such a degree that it's
often difficult to define what it really
means
but i just want different points of view
expressed that's what i'm really saying
we were having a conversation before the
camera started rolling about margaret
thatcher and in this country she's even
though she died a few years ago she
still is a fantastically divisive figure
and you were actually saying that there
were certain qualities of hers and
things that you did that she did that
you found quite admirable and i'll be
honest with you uh
coming from a guardian journalist i
found that quite shocking what is it
about maggie that was that you thought
was
good and necessary at the time
well she she
made decisions and approached uh issues
of the day um in a way that had not been
confronted for the previous particular
previous 10 20 years and and needed
confronting and no one had the guts to
do it um she did it often crudely um she
did it
often haphazardly and she did it with a
a lack of sympathy and charm which
caused a great damage no question about
that
but i mean it's been like a bit like the
interwar years i mean you've got to go
back to the 1970s
the 19 1970 to 1976 789
you really thought britain was finished
you actually thought i mean quite apart
from winters of discontent and rubbish
piling in the streets and so on which
was quite so toxic to the political life
of the country um every other country
thought we were dead
the british disease
was i mean the the british disease must
not infect europe as an obsession and we
were members of the european community
and people say how can we stop the
british disease affecting europe and
that disease was over powerful trade
unions um
monopolies state monopolies uh the
statehood half the half of what now is
the private sector it was extraordinary
and no one in the callahan wilson
governments then had the guts to
confront it ted heath did for two years
and then perfuncted and
it's great u-turn um politics in the 70s
was britain at his most desperate
and in 197 the 1979 the 1980 um party
conference season i remember well
everybody said mrs thatcher's finished
she's been so unpopular uh i mean no
one's going to vote for mrs thatcher and
i remember i was in the political lobby
then um everyone's taking bets on this
and i i just i just like i'm like i am
now i said she's fine she'll you know
she'll come around she won't she won't
be gone by christmas i remember so five
or six senior political registers
betting me
10 quid she'll be gone by christmas and
i collected from half of them um
never pay up um but uh but um
but but the the the fact is by the late
80s
was on a roll
and it was on a roll largely because of
things done by mrs thatcher or her
government
um and it was the star of europe now
that transformation
took place under that woman
and i was the fact
and by the 90s you know we were actually
creaming ahead
but but that was almost inconceivable in
the 70s
and so why is is that being the case why
is that
why is she so divisive then why does she
instill such rage and anger even now
30 years after her government i i think
we're sitting in the east end of london
and saying that i mean i'm not quite
sure people feel quite that strongly
about it elsewhere um
they do in scotland where i lived for
many years they do in some parts of the
north some people okay
well the reason is that she traumatized
them no question about it she
traumatized them i mean she
mining which is a great sort of cultural
sweep of england
was burning she ended it
steel collapsed onto her british cars
were useless and she said so um
she she privatized great swades of
industry which would heavily protect
shipbuilding by by the state um all
those interest groups suffered
um and uh and uh you know
this at the same time she was not
showing any great
charm or sympathy with nhs or for those
things no she was unpopular no question
about that um
and on top of that god does anyone who
interviewed her knew she had no personal
sympathy with with these people you know
the famous stories about her going off
to work in the morning
and the children would wave at her from
the upstairs room she never turned back
whereas her husband turned back and
waved i mean
she was a difficult person
and and i just i just think that that
you know one has to set these things to
one side um
i mean one one's criticizing boris
johnson for being boris johnson people
criticized mrs thatcher for being mrs
thatcher you've got a certain point in
the argument to set this to one side
saying are they doing the right thing
and um and i think on the whole she did
the right thing no necessary thing not
the right thing
it's curious as you're talking it makes
me think and you know i said when kier
starman became leader of the labour
party i said he needs to pick a fight
with the extremist in his own party
get them out and do the right thing he
hasn't done that in my opinion but do
you think it's an inevitable part of
strong and good political leadership
that you're going to do things that
work for the country but maybe
really don't work for some people and
that's the price you have to pay if
you're actually going to get things done
but like clearly the answer is yes um
and i think i mean
blair blair's most impressive period was
the two years before he became prime
minister absolutely and i remember
interviewing him then and i think this
is this is this is i mean he he he took
on the party constitution he took on the
national executive he confronted all
these pressure groups in within his own
party um
was talked to him about electoral mayors
election elected mayors and the great
sales pitch for elected mayors for tony
blair was they they might smash local
labour parties
that's what he saw as as the opportunity
he told me to my face um so you you're
right he he understood he had a group
around him who understood he could work
with it that he had to transform the
labour party
now i think it's more difficult at the
moment because i don't think the labour
party is institutionally
anything like
blair was handling um
its problem is he's got a lot of rather
weak leaders who talk the wrong language
at the moment because of the nature of
the groups within the labour party who
support them
i do think the red wall thing is is
significant i mean i i do think that the
labour party is going to realize he's
got to win these people back and it will
not win them back
without entity politics
it just won't it's not the way to do it
what's wrong with that anti-politician i
think it's really damaging i think
identity i think identity politics is is
the i mean the essence of democracy to
me is one man one one woman one vote and
person one vote
and and um and if you if you if you
and the differences that arise within a
well-organized democracy are differences
of opinion on policy how do we want our
country to be run how do we how do we
want to live um how do we want to treat
people um
can we bring ourselves given the fact
that not everyone's the same but we're
treating them as the same
for democratic purposes they got one
vote
we have to pretend in a sense that we
are all equal
if you start saying um
um
i regard you as privileged and myself is
underprivileged so i want positive
discrimination in my favor or i want to
organize my politics around my group not
what we think
um i just think you you undermine
democracy i really do
and i think i think if you if you if you
move down the route of of um people
voting as groups this is what happens in
you know iraq
you vote with your with your with your
family or group whatever it might be you
do not vote for anything other than that
and your interest there is your interest
when you're voting for your pocketbook
or your job or whatever it is you're
going to be able to grip
and the idea of equality of opportunity
of the quality of
treatment or quality of approach
um it goes out of the window
if you go too far too far down that
particular route
one of the problems has certainly been
that certain groups in british society
historically
the poor the celts uh immigrants whoever
it might be
have not been treated equally and now
they've
found a way of mobilizing that
sense of discrimination or sense of
failure to their advantage
and a large chunk of the community feels
guilty
in responding to that and it's that
guilt that leads them to either make
wrong decisions or not to get in the way
of people who are making wrong decisions
which is the the ultimate danger in
democracy it's not enough for
evil to triumph
just for good people to stay silent i
mean if you stay silent in the face of
some of these things that are happening
then they will go on happening
and it's mobilizing the silent majority
which has always been the great sort of
cliche of democracy it's mobilizing the
silent
majority that holds the the way out of
this and i think we will get out of it
um it's a sort of
a temporary hysteria but it's certainly
very vivid if you're a victim of it
and that's do you think that's a
controversial opinion to have if you're
a member of the labour party on the left
this crit this critique of identity
politics i don't think so i mean i think
because everyone talks about it all the
time
and
would you write something like this in
the guardian oh yeah
yeah i mean
well i mean
i know i
i've never felt i can't
you know write in the guardian i mean
they print what i write twice a week i
mean or they put it online um no i mean
i i i i
it's probably the way you express it i
mean and i i do think that that um
i mean you know i would spend a year at
sussex university you know and i've i've
decided to disassociate myself
completely from it because of what they
did down there i thought it was just
outrageous
she was in the chair yesterday oh really
yeah um i think you're thinking of
returning my honorary degree um
but um but uh
i mean i i i i hey i don't think we you
can't continue like this i mean you can
see what's happened in america america
has this wonderful i mean you know
america
goes right to the extreme and then
virginia votes out the democrat votes
would rather have trump than this
rubbish you're teaching us um
uh
california
sane on drugs
um you know
america is both the most [ __ ]
country and also the most advanced and
it's fascinating for that reason um
i don't know how it's going to act out
um but all i just do know is is that
i'm sure you had them in this chair i
mean
thousands of people not millions of
people don't go along with it
and um and almost all the people i talk
to agree with me and knew on the subject
so um
i just i just think we'll get over it
francis is having a meltdown here
because because for once someone is
being positive about the future and he
can't handle it go on may god tell us
about how depressed you are god it's
what the people want to hear it's what
they this what they come for with
trigonometry and francis foster go on
mate
i'm i'm a rabid pessimist simon and look
there's a part of me i'm like all
pessimists i enjoy my pessimism i enjoy
it i revel in it
i roll around in it every day i wear it
but
i
my problem and joking aside is i don't
see a way out
and when i don't see a way out of a
problem
that's when
the panic starts to arise
and i look at the labour party and i
look at the figures
i don't see someone with conviction i
don't see someone with passion i don't
see someone who can galvanize i don't
see anyone who can challenge
if i'm going to be blunt
i don't think i see many people with a
backbone and that's what worries me even
if they disagreed with me if they had a
backbone and go no
this is what i think
i'd be far more likely to vote for that
person
well you you i i saw the list you've had
plenty of people in this chair who who
say that or
who got backbone i think
and i mean many friends of mine and you
know i i admire their outspokenness um
and but i mean you're asking me very
specific questions about the past and
the relationship between the past and
the present and i try to set the present
in the context of the past because as
the cliche goes you won't know the
future if you don't so we have an
obligation
people of intelligence or whatever have
an obligation to look to the past to
learn from it um and and i i i that
things happen in britain always which
have distressed me no end and the things
happening now which distress me and when
it when when i see
people behaving towards other people in
a way that that used to happen in
totalitarian countries um
i mean
some people some people not many people
today treat other people they disagree
with much as the pre-reformation church
teach
talk
treated heretics i mean yeah and and i
think to myself gosh if these people
were there then they'd be doing the
burning of the state you know yeah and
and i just think
are they aware of that i mean i i
remember my family i may say a young um
young practical
recently student
who says you'll not get there they're
always in television they're always
there you've got your way your your
voice out so yeah let us have a go i
mean we have this sort of
unconstructive conversation
but i mean uh i i sort of take a point i
mean if i genuinely thought that the
right-wing press is being shut down by
the cultural warriors then i would worry
uh there's not the slightest sign of
that happening um there's not the
slightest sign of that of their critics
not appearing on the bbc uh not
appearing on your show and so on so i
just don't think things are as
catastrophic as you're implying
and um okay well if you're asking me if
you're asking me could i please give you
the road map out then that's much more
difficult i'd grant you yeah okay so
let me help france it's unusual with me
because i tried to be the positive one
but
we you talk about rewriting of history
for example i mean what happened last
year to me and i'm
i'm from russia i'm from a jewish
background so all this white guilt
nonsense doesn't apply to me i just it's
nothing to do with me my ancestors
didn't enslave anyone my ancestors were
slaves right so i don't buy into any of
this crap to me what happened in this
country last year when you had police
officers being told don't shoot when
they don't carry firearms kneeling to an
organization that wants to defund them
and the entirety of the media class
entirety of the the political class all
virtually bowing the head
bending the knee whatever you want to
say to this absolute garbage that's come
over from america has got nothing to do
with the history of britain right we
don't have black people being shot by
police in this country this absurdity
and yet very very few people had the
back bonus francis has to stand up
against it and now you're seeing you
talk about crt in america it is being
taught in this country as well right and
people we've had people in that chair
simon who go i don't agree with it it's
completely wrong but my kids go to a
school where this happens and i'm afraid
to challenge it
to tell me that is not the path to ruin
uh
it is it's the path through if it were
to be uh the generality of what's
happening in this country as it was in
virginia
i mean there are
there are schools in
the united kingdom
uh which i came across at least 10 years
ago where they still teach creationism
they're places in the united kingdom and
i'm talking about northern ireland here
you know where where where um you know
abortion is passionately opposed um
where the most rabid conservative
opinions still rule
and we don't do anything about it it's
the united liberal united kingdom
uh peace walls dividing our cities in
the united kingdom
i can't get anyone excited about that i
want to playing northern irish you know
um now i'm not defending it i'm not not
attacking it but
i just try to keep these things in
perspective
uh
the the things that you're referring to
last year
the the reaction to it was instantaneous
and fierce i mean the the the the you
know the home secretary the police they
all said this is a mistake it's like
people who stopped the traffic getting
onto the roads which is it raises
everybody your your strength of feeling
i imagine is shared by 60 70 of the
population
and i just don't think it has any chance
of becoming what might be called the the
like motif of
british education policy or social
policy i just don't um
yeah there's some crazies about there
always been some crazies about i mean
when i was a student everything was
vietnam vietnam and vietnam and vietnam
why did you know more about vietnam i do
with media now it's playing outside of
the world
oh well what's wrong with you you know
you've got some problem and you know
come on come on this march you're gonna
smash something down um
okay let me try again on a different
subject now
uh you mentioned muslim countries and
you mentioned that we've had a number of
terrorist attacks in this country in
recent days which
have been happening for a long time and
statistically speaking extremely
unlikely to affect anyone watching this
listening to this the tiny tiny issue in
terms of
the number of people killed in terms of
number of people physically affected
but again the reaction you know this
this liverpool bomber that that was
talked about as a christian convert and
we all just by like the telegraph the
telegraph for writing an article going
christian convert bombs really are we
buying into this idea that this guy was
actually a christian convert we're gonna
just run with that
do you know what i mean so there's a
cowardice about naming the problem on
that issue don't you think
yeah i think quentin was just who you're
referring to i mean
and i got questions about terrorism and
terrorism is a crime yeah it should not
be treated political at all most of
these people are mad in some degree
they've got problems um
they shouldn't be in this country or
they should be locked up or whatever i'm
quite tough on that yeah um but what i
what i refuse to do is to recast my
society
because politicians and the media so
exaggerate the threat
uh i mean the threat from
drug gangs is far worse than they agree
but we just live with it you know we
agree with it now i mean we live with
these terrorist outrages um and uh and
um and i i i
my point is more about the fact that we
refuse to be honest about the issue
but if you when when uh sir david ames
was killed the politicians started
talking about online anonymity as if
that had anything to do with this guy
stabbing him right uh the same with so
my point is we refuse to talk about the
issue and i take your point about drug
gangs we've had tony solo on the show to
talk about the impact in in that
community
but
my worry is that we are no longer having
an honest conversation honest
conversation about so many issues to me
that is the path to ruin as well so i'm
just trying to help francis out but well
i mean
i
free speech is an absolute
uh except of course it isn't
so you say well when i'm hanging out
with the home secretary once about about
about this cause of concept
you're causing offence as a crime how do
you define a fence if someone feels
offended you mean the person who's the
victim defines the crime well that's
where we are at the moment you know well
i mean i think this is crazy i agree and
i mean this was this was 20 years ago um
now
it it if anything not quite as crazy now
as it was then
but um other forms of craziness have
takeo taken over and i imagine they
always will
um if people haven't got big things to
worry about they'll find smaller things
to worry about and make the smaller
things big and that's what's happening
with free speech at the moment um
to my mind it's absolutely absurd that
you you try and institutionalize the
reaction to people who say unfortunate
words or whatever it might be and this
position cricket and so on it says it's
no good i'm not defending it i'm just
simply saying
there has to be a sense of proportion in
our response to it and we've lost that
sense of proportion partly because
enough people have got a vested interest
in keeping this ball rolling
um
to every single paper when you open the
page there's another story about it um i
just i mean i just don't think it's
going to i don't think it's something
else to take its place i mean terrorism
the word terrorism was on every page of
every newspaper every day more or less
um and there's one covered private eye
said we mustn't we must be terrorized
into fear
what it was on other pages panics
yeah it's a very good thing i i just i
just i i'm coming back to this rather
relentless theme
about about in political debate although
the debater like socrates has a vested
interest in in digging up
his or her side of the argument um the
the the important thing in the outcome
which is why you have judges who aren't
decided so to speak um is to put it in
proportion
and getting it into proportion is the
most difficult political task
of all political tasks
it's easier to say what the problem is
it's easy to say the solution is getting
it into proportion that's much more
difficult
simon
uh well constantine's from russia
my family one half of them are
venezuelan and over covid
alarm bells started to ring more and
more in my head particularly when it
came to journalistic freedoms
particularly after what happened matt
hancock he was deservedly fired for what
he did uh
breaking the uh the covert regulations
and then pretty patel trying to pass the
bill i don't i lost track of it i don't
know if it was passed where if a
journalist would seem to humiliate the
government they could spend 14 years in
jail
maximum sentence where do you see
journalistic freedoms now do you think
they're as free as they've ever been or
do you think there's been an effort by
the government in order to try and
restrict them
well
there's always the latter
[Laughter]
through spike the spike actually like a
couple of the dates of spy catcher it
was amazing the government simply said
you aren't allowed to say or do anything
that we don't let you i mean it was
almost at that level about areas of
government um
uh i'm a great supporter of index on
censorship and and and other groups like
that um uh internews i mean though
they're important groups that champion
general supreme around the world um i
went to speak in colombia once under the
old regime i mean
i mean
a quarter at least so the people i was
talking to now dead um i mean to be a
journalist in these countries is to be
brave
um i don't think i'd be very brave in
this country i really don't um and and i
also think it's a
booming profession
people always say that it's dead it's
not dead more journalists being employed
every year than the year before i think
most of them in social media and all
these sorts of activities but they're in
employment and investigative journalism
has never been so vigorous i mean the
panama papers i mean all these these
things and and the the wikileaks things
the guardian was doing um are major
major disclosures of secret areas of the
state and of the private sector which
were completely hidden before
and it's worth going back and looking at
a newspaper we were having this argument
so and i said right let's get every copy
of the daily papers from
1955. 1960 1965 you sit down and read
them
they are beyond belief dull i mean 90 of
it was just reporting what happened in
parliament or the courts
um and there was there was
nothing revelatory or
sensational
tabloids were slightly different but but
the quality of the journalism was
appalling by comparison today
and i just do think that that i mean you
just you just seen it with sleaze i mean
these these guys weren't killing people
i mean they were
doing dodgy things which they shouldn't
be doing all right i'm not defending it
but but i mean
they're killed i mean the the the
savagery
of the press response to them i just i
think he's over the top i really do and
i got some sympathy with boris johnson
some of his respect okay i'll push back
i'm afraid i agree i agree with you
um so like i said my mother's from
venezuela i saw what corruption does if
you don't challenge corruption if you
don't root out corruption corruption is
like a cancer it will spread its
tentacles into every aspect of society
and ultimately it with the society will
crumble as a result i've seen it with my
own eyes
i think you need when a corruption
happens or when you see it it needs to
be ripped out
and it needs to be attacked
otherwise what will happen is like i
just said and that's a doomsday scenario
but i've seen it would you not agree
with that i would i mean i i i i i would
very strongly i mean i i it's one of the
reasons why i go to venezuela a few
times and it's a lovely country when i
was absolutely marvelous rich too yeah
um but um but you know it it it it went
wrong
and
the question then is what do i do about
it i mean i can say that i can
commiserate
is it my business
i'm not so sure
i'm in a country which is probably any
country in the world where you can go
into the public marketplace and buy
yourself a seat in parliament
as a peer
you can actually buy yourself a seat in
parliament i find that staggering
i find no country that tolerates that is
entitled to criticize any other country
for the quality of their democracy as
long as that's the case in this country
and yet
people shrug and they smile they do the
things they're doing in turkey and they
do in brazil and so
oh well you know it's it's life
it's not life it it it is as long as
you're selling seats in parliament it's
not life it's corrupt
um british politics i had a trouble
around the bbc because i said it was
corrupt in some
news program you can't use that word
you've got to be able to prove it oh
should we have a court case let's let's
let's discuss it in court you know yeah
this this poor presenter has obviously
been told never to allow the word
corrupt be applied to the conservative
government i can't believe it but but i
mean i i think
i'm really saying is is it's a
complicated message
the terms of the debate matter
if you want other people to disagree
with you to be persuaded by you you've
got to go in a sense some way into the
conversation to establish the rules of
the game
when when kenneth clark was doing his
great series on civilization he was
asked in the very last program what are
the defining qualities of of of a
civilized country
and he said very interestingly he said i
think actually
it's it's the courtesy of public debate
interesting word courtesy and it's
rather what i'm discussing here now it's
the terms in which you conduct this
debate um do you
do you hold your head in your hands and
scream or burst into tears or shouts or
whatever
or do you say why do you think that i
mean what why do you you know try to say
to my niece why do you think that
um all right you think it's true but do
you first you do respect my not agreeing
with you do you use the word respect at
all in terms of this conversation
but having established respect we then
have rules in which we conduct this and
those rules are governed by what i call
courtesy
um i i think i've actually pointed out
freedom and freedom of speech i mean i
think these are the these are the
essential qualities of freedom of speech
not just being allowed to shout louder
than the other guy
no absolutely right
but i think france's point i i hear what
you're saying is and i agree to me i'll
be honest with you maybe this is my
russian background but it's like
politicians being corrupt i saw the
blair government they were exactly the
same exactly the same in the same way
that these guys are doing what they're
doing those people were taking cash for
questions and all of that stuff right
this was all happening and i kind of see
it as a sort of should be condemned
should something someone somewhere
should do something about it really but
it's kind of the price of doing business
isn't it
well i mean and you you've seen with the
with these i i we have not heard the end
of this yet but 38 billion pounds
was swirling around whitehall for about
six months over
test and trace and ppe the beginning of
the pandemic
and it was as if it was if you were
suddenly in in in in russia 1990
yep i mean everybody's like jesus christ
i can make a fortune
well you sure you could i can make a
fortune well it's not right i can make a
fortune i mean people were
just
into that trough
abrasive shakes and the system helped
them
and we don't know where 30 or
probably more like 20 now but we don't
know where 20 billion went i i don't
doubt at the national audience office
will ever find out
this was a deeply corrupt period there
were reasons for it you know governments
were panicking but nonetheless when you
suspend the rules of the game you get
corruption and oh and i'll push back
once more simon so
we have we have a housing crisis in this
country which is having a huge untold
impact on the lives of young people on
birth rates on society
and no government whether labor or
conservatives has done a lot to change
that they haven't done a lot to solve
the problem the problem has continually
got worse johnson when he got elected
one of his pledges was that he was going
to do something about it michael gove
gets 120 grand from housing companies
all of a sudden
it's been shelved to the back now are
those two things connected i'm not sure
but you know what once again we kick a
huge societal problem we kick the can
further down the road well
i don't agree
we have no highs in crisis we have a
housing market
the housing market
houses most british people perfectly
satisfactorily apart from the homeless
who i do worry about
um
the the the the place where the housing
crisis is supposed to be worst is london
okay london has the youngest labor force
and the youngest population in britain
they live somewhere
um the tradition that everyone who
should have their own own their own
house at the age of 30 is absurd it
applies in no other country it was
started by thatcher my friend not yours
you said everyone everyone has a right
to a house to own a house um and she
sold off public housing stock to these
people who immediately rented it out
profit but but um
i just don't see this housing i mean
every country in the world the economist
every week has house prices going up by
faster than inflation
the biggest problem is we under use
houses that's the crisis in london in
particular london has the lowest house
occupancy of any city in europe
we've got sort of two bedrooms for every
person
and the reason for that is the taxation
system does not tax properties it should
and we tax housing transfers through
stamp duty which means that no one has
invested has any interest in selling
their large house and getting into a
smaller one so all housing policies
crazy
but i just don't i don't see a crisis
the only crisis is homelessness and that
is what
we're we're pouring money into first
time buying which media increases the
price so the taxpayer is increasing
house prices yes yeah they're really
there but simon come on home but come on
you say there's no housing crisis you've
got young people who are living five to
a flat what that means is they're not
going to get they're not going to be
getting married they're not going to be
having children that affects their
outlook on life it means they act in
less mature ways frankly we see it with
our generation
the the percentage of your of your
income that is spent on housing is
rising rapidly for young people in
particular
it's what i paid
percentage-wise yeah i paid 35 of my
income when i was young on my house
it was crazy i was buying a flat i
shouldn't be i shouldn't have been
renting i'd settle you buy a house in
germany you buy a house and you settle
uh you rent otherwise uh we're now back
to the renting levels that we had you
know
quite some time ago before the house
buying boom got went out of hand which
never did in germany incidentally it's
quite interesting how different places
are um
the word this word crisis goes with the
word housing as if it's one phrase
i mean there's not a transport crisis or
a food crisis or anything there's a
housing crisis because
we're so used to using the phrase that
the housing the house building lobby
always use um
no
i just think i think government ought to
be in housing except for very very poor
people
but the problem is the government isn't
housing and it's messing everything up
wait is it messing it up by by
effectively subsidizing house by house
yes and the house prices go up but but
people still buy houses and people still
live in london i mean they're scandals
scandals are empty property scandals as
foreigners buying houses are not living
in them that i deal with
but but but there there are
all i can say is you walk the streets of
london i mean
you can then walk the street to
manchester it's as if there are two age
groups
london is just so young now
i mean they look i live five to flat
ones i mean come on
but do you not think
that it's a problem where people can't
see a way out of a rental situation
where they have no hope in
being able to afford to buy a place
because house prices have increased a
huge amount
and wages haven't kept up surely that's
the problem simon
it's not a problem it's a fact
if it is a fact i mean
it is all the younger people i know seem
somehow to find somewhere to live all i
can say
may not be where they want to live
people always want a better house so
that the demand always exceeds supply so
the concept of housing need is
meaningless it's used by the government
so there's no marxist concept the indus
survival of marxism and british
government is the concept of housing
need um
as if there's a fixed number of people
in a fixed number of houses there aren't
it's a highly fluid market i can get the
streets in suburban manchester you can
walk along empty street after empty
street after empty street
you can find that in parts of the west
midlands empty street after empty street
there's plenty of houses not only that
but they're all they're all carbon sinks
i mean the last thing we should be is
demolishing and building blocks of flats
which we're continuing to do
but but people want to live in the
southeast
house prices go up in the southeast as
they go up in sydney and melbourne san
francisco and los angeles around new
york
britain is is in the lower half
of world capitals in terms of house
price increase in inflation just look at
the facts so there's a lot of jobs to do
occasionally um it is not a problem it's
it's it's it's a it's a need people want
better houses there's no question about
that and they all want to live in the
countryside and they want to drive to
work they want to not have to
sweat on the commuter trains
it may well be that's going to be
the the new pattern now after lockdown i
don't think so but it may be
but but i mean you you can literally do
what everyone wants
and you can you can simply build houses
over the whole of of kent and east
anglia and that's what people will want
that's what people they will demand i'll
keep on saying there's a crisis because
i can't get what i want
but
people starting out on life often have
trouble living in the space they can
afford it's not nothing new about that
um
housing standards in britain the better
than they've ever been in history so
there's not there wasn't some golden age
when everybody has exactly the house
they wanted and um
possibly between the wars which sort of
golden age um but no i i just i just
don't recognize this word crisis i just
don't all right
simon
sorry
no it's fine it's fine this is the
nature of everything is fine and as a
result francis is going to get more
depressed than he usually is
but simon it's been a pleasure chatting
with you we've got a couple of questions
for our local supporters but before we
wrap up the interview where we end with
one final question which is of course
what is the one thing we're not talking
about as a society that we really should
be
i think well i i just i'm always
fascinated by taboos and i i given what
we were talking about as are we as you
can tell they're mercifully slightly
fewer than they were but but there's
always a new taboo bubbling along um
and and because of my past interest in
the subject i've always felt that
there's a curious taboo about about um
pleasures that other people have but we
don't have
of which
classic one is taking soft drugs or
taking drugs in general i regard
drugs as a menace
and
serious drugs or the serious minis um
but the handling of drugs
fascinates me because over over the
whole western world not so much the
eastern world we simply don't know what
to do about it we can have we reckon we
can handle alcohol which is a very
serious drug we can handle obesity we
think which is a serious drug or the
result of a serious drug um
we handle smoking rather successfully we
didn't handle it by banning smoking we
banned it we handled it by regulating
smoking but but um recreational drugs as
they're called
in some sense rightly so
absolutely defeat us when the united
nations
went along with nixon in declaring war
on drugs
it's it's ruined half a dozen latin
american countries including
maybe venezuela um i mean i was in peru
and i couldn't believe
the the the wreckage
the american drugs market has caused on
these countries in which mexican mexico
is the most devastating
entirely by drugs the entire criminal
class is built on drugs
the same is true in large parts of
europe it's through a number of english
cities the county alliance phenomenon is
it's brought an extraordinary degree of
criminal activity and we just can't
handle it we just can't handle it and
the result is
that we when i was on the committee it
was reviewing the 1973 drugs act um
it has been changed
that's half a century of this problem we
haven't begun to tackle it and i just
find it so depressing
that that that the government which now
has examples around the world of all
sorts of different ways of tackling it
in this country is one of the most
backward and unreconstructed and i i
almost give up well germany is about to
decriminalize cannabis
do you think decriminalization is is the
solution for for those types of drugs i
i
i decriminalize all drugs
i would
decriminalize all things there's no
point in criminalizing a market it's
like going to the gulf and criminalizing
oil
it's like that
everybody's in this business all right
we'll have to do it under the counter
i think you you decriminalize it yes um
but you regulate it you just regulate
like you regulate tobacco you regulate
drink i mean all these things are
regulated there's no reason why this
shouldn't be regulated and what's so
fascinating now is that about six states
in america are doing it diff they're all
doing it differently
some it's working colorado it's working
some it's not california is not working
very well
but but but they're all at least taking
a great chunk of quotes criminal
activity out of the criminal severe
and sooner or later prison population
will come down police will be less
worried about this one particular crime
um
mental health can get into operation to
tackle people with drug problems which
is a huge issue
we underestimate how massive
the consequence is of criminalizing
drugs
i couldn't agree with you more on that
one simon been an absolute pleasure
thank you so much for coming on uh where
can people find your work you write for
the guardian obviously is anything else
people should go and see any books they
should check out
any good bookshop fantastic look up
simon jenkins thank you uh for watching
and listening at home or wherever you've
been and i will see you very soon with
another brilliant episode like this one
or raw show all of them go out 7pm uk
time and for those of you who like your
trigonometry on the go it's also
available as a podcast take care and see
you soon guys
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe and hit
the bell button so that you never miss
another fantastic episode and if you
believe that the work we do here at
trigonometry is important support us by
joining our locals community using the
link below